Good afternoon, everybody, and welcome. My name is Bishoy Faltas.
I'm a medical oncologist and a physician scientist at Weill Cornell
Medicine. I am delighted to be joined today by Dr.
Matthew Galsky from the Mount Sinai School of Medicine,
and Dr. Philip Abbash from the Fox Chase Cancer Center.
These are my disclosures.
So over the last 10 years, there has been a
revolution in treatment of bladder cancer,
and that has really extended across the entire disease
spectrum. And I'm going to show you some examples of this.
So in BCG refractory non-muscle invasive bladder cancer,
has been an unmet medical need for many years.
We have witnessed an explosion of new intravesical and
systemic therapies with significant improvement in the
12-month complete response rate, as you can see here.
The point I'm trying to make is not really to compare across different
studies or trials, but rather to show you the trend
is definitely pointing upward and there is a number of
treatments beyond traditional intravesical chemotherapy,
targeted therapies, gene therapies, and immunotherapy.
In the neoadjuvant setting for muscle-invasive bladder cancer, we're
seeing dramatic improvement in the complete response rates
with combinations of the antibody drug conjugates such as
enfortumab vedotin and immune checkpoint inhibitors,
including pembrolizumab, that now make bladder
preservation for the first time a realistic
possibility for many of our patients.
In patients with metastatic bladder cancer, which traditionally
is the most serious stage of the disease, if you
look over the span of the last few years, we've now
doubled the overall survival with EV-pembro,
which is now a median of 31 and a half months, which
before was something completely unheard of.
So today, we'll cover the full range of these advances in the
management of these different disease states.
So first, we're going to have Dr. Abbash, who will talk to us about
advances in risk stratification and appropriate
management of non-muscle invasive bladder cancer.
And I thank him for agreeing to speak today on a
short notice as Dr. Kamat, unfortunately, was unable to
join us today. So thank you, Phil.
Dr. Galsky will give us an overview of his work on how
to highly active therapies and precision biomarkers
are converging to redefine care. And finally, I'll
share with you some of our thoughts on these breakthroughs
and translational priorities.
So with that,
it is my pleasure to introduce Dr. Phil Abbash.
Dr. Abbash is a surgeon scientist in Philadelphia.
His lab is at the Fox Chase Cancer Center, where he is
interested in urine biomarkers of response to pre-surgical
therapies. His clinic is at the Einstein Medical Center, where he
treats patients in North Philadelphia. Thank you, Dr.
Abbash.
Okay, thanks a lot, Bishoy. This is a real
surprise. I got a message from Bishoy this morning.
Ashish, I think, is out there listening.
You guys can all have your collective groan.
I'm going to do my best here. I made it through the slides a couple of times, so I
think I can do a good job here for you.
So,
these are all Ashish's slides, so I don't want to take too much credit here.
But we're
going to talk a lot about therapy for non-muscle invasive
bladder cancer. It's both pre and post BCG.
I have a couple disclosures, but nothing really relevant to what we're going to
talk about today. So, the overview.
We're going to first just set the stage and talk about the little
epidemiology about bladder cancer.
We'll talk about
the
molecular and clinical heterogeneity that we have
to figure out in order to prescribe the right therapies.
That'll lead into a discussion about risk stratification.
We'll talk about BCG and some of the new evolving therapies that
Bishoy alluded to.
We'll talk a lot about BCG on responsive disease, and then a future directions,
couple of slides. So, just the epidemiology here.
Worldwide, over half a million cases of bladder cancer
per year. It's one of the most common cancers.
Most of these are going to be superficial tumors, non-muscle
invasive bladder cancer. And it is a very expensive disease to treat.
Over $300,000 over the lifetime of the patient, and a
lot of that's because of surveillance, the high risk of recurrence
of non-muscle invasive tumors, and the expense of treating patients who have
maybe more locally advanced
cystectomy, tends to be a complicated, expensive procedure.
And then, of course, metastatic disease costs are going to balloon, and
we'll talk about that a little bit as well.
So
staging biology here.
I'm not going to belabor this because I think everybody probably knows a lot about
it already. But
non-muscle invasive disease is typically you get Ta, T1,
and these CIS flat lesions. Each of them has their own kind of
biology and genetics.
I think this is actually from Ashish's paper a couple of years ago in "The Lancet"
that had a really nice
broad summary of bladder cancer genetics in the field
at the time. One of the things that we'll talk about several times here
is the staging
systems have changed over the years.
And then this is actually now leading to molecular, I wouldn't call it
staging, but classification systems.
And you can see that there's some overlap, but it's not perfect
as these things have evolved.
So this is probably one of the most widely used
molecular staging
classifications.subtyping, I should say, based on
RNA expression profiles. I think early on it was like cDNA
arrays and now RNA-seq.
But you can essentially divide non-muscle invasive bladder cancer into
four of these subgroups,
with class one
being mostly FGFR3-driven disease.
These tend to be the low-grade papillary things that we probably most
commonly see.
Class two has been split into two groups.
There's a kind of chromosomally
unstable APABEC, which I'll hear Bashar talk about
in a little bit, is a really important driver of the genetics of
that kind of disease. And then this T1 high-grade
intermediate aggressiveness category.
And then class three, which actually more
has genetics of muscle-invasive disease with chromosomal
instability, aneuploidy, p53 loss, and again, APABEC.
So we're
going to talk a lot about staging here.
And this is something Ashish has been very much a thought leader in this
area.
Traditionally, we've sort of had low, intermediate, and high
risk that are all
assigned based on clinical findings, so size of tumor,
multiplicity of tumor,
history of intravesical therapy treatment, and of course,
that risk refers really
to the risk of recurrence and progression.
Both of these are obviously untoward outcomes, but
progression typically meaning progressing to muscle-invasive disease, which would
typically require chemotherapy from my medical oncology
colleagues, and/or cystectomy.
Maybe simplify it isn't the right word, but maybe more
like a risk-based calculator with these five factors with the
IBCG.
Ashish is very much a leader within the International
Bladder Cancer Group. These are essentially risk factors that
you can use to assign risk stages based on the
number of factors that are present for the patient
in front of you. This probably, in some ways, does simplify
the stratification.
And these were actually formally adopted, and I think this is something we should
all be really proud of, that this came from a working group
that my colleagues are part of that really is changing the way we take care of
patients.
Okay. We'll talk about now high-risk disease that's pre-BCG.
So this is a
sub-stratification of the original stratification that I just mentioned a minute
ago. So this is just within high risk.
You have
high risk, high grade Ta, high risk, high grade T1, and
high risk CIS.
And these, again, all have their own
risk of progression.
And so again, this is a sub-stratification just within the high risk.
You can use these risk stratifications to
try to project what's going to happen, and then, of course, to assign
a more personalized therapy. So BCG
is actually the original cancer immunotherapy.
It was given to patients with melanoma and then patients with bladder
cancer. The timeline of this stretches all the way back to
1970. So
Bernie Zbar
kind of started giving this to patients at NCI, and
then Al Morales is credited with giving
BCG as intravesical therapy. This was in the
1970s.
We went 20 years, essentially, with just BCG.
In 1990, it was still BCG, but Don Lamb, at that time,
introduced maintenance BCG, where you give BCG three months
later, six months later, instead of just that one first six-week
time course. And then there's this long period where nothing really
happened until we started giving BCG with other
immunotherapies, and then immunotherapy, of course, burst on the
scene with durvalumab and these
other PD-1 checkpoint. So there's a couple of
trials I think we'll just talk about that
incorporated
IO therapy. So, the ALBAN trial was unfortunately a negative
trial looking at atezolizumab in combination with
BCG. CREST was this
cisatuzumab, another
anti-PD-1 therapy, given with two years of BCG, resulted
in a 32% reduction in a 24-month event-free survival
and a significant reduction in the high-grade recurrence.
And then the POTOMAC trial looked at durvalumab plus BCG, which again was
positive, again increased disease-free survival.
I'll note that although these don't necessarily result in overall survival benefit,
that
there's a little bit of a patient-driven factor there, too, for the relevant
outcome for the patient, because
if you're avoiding more invasive or more intense therapies, such as for
metastatic disease or cystectomy, there may still be a reason to pursue
those kinds of treatments.
The EFS in CREST was consistent across all
subgroups, so
that again
supports the effectiveness of the therapy.
So this is hearkening back to the
subtype, the RNA subtyping. And this is actually data from Matt, so I'll
credit Matt here.
So the colorful Kaplan-Meier curves in A and B,
on the left is going to be the curve for the
combined therapy, and on the right is BCG alone.
And if you just
bring your attention to the red curve, you'll see that when you combine on the left
with IO, BCG with IO, there's a
higher EFS rate over the course of the
trial.As opposed to BCG alone, suggesting that you might, and these
aren't clinic ready yet, but the idea is you can potentially
risk stratify patients based on not just their clinical
stage, but their molecular subtype.
And of course, you don't see those
gradations, those differences if you just look at the survival of the
BCG versus BCG IO cohort on the right.
Those molecular classifications,
whether you use the Euromol or the TCGA
classification system, again, now
keep an eye on the green curve there.
So the green curve is the luminal subtype.
Does
not quite so well with
BCG alone, but really does well with the BCG plus
IO. So now we'll turn our attention to the BCG
unresponsive state. So, I mentioned
this long trough where there was not a lot of new therapies.
So 1998, Valrubicin was approved.
This is intravesical cytotoxic chemotherapy.
And then
this desert of new therapies
prompted
Ashish and others to approach the FDA about like, "We need to
design new trials, we need new drugs, we need new outcomes." And that
has precipitated a lot of new
therapies. So
after those meetings,
we came up with a new framework for designing clinical trials and what control
arms are needed, if any. And now we're at a point where things
are starting to really accelerate, where we have things like IO that
I just talked about,
intravesical adenoviral agents,
IL-15 agonists, and then TAR200, this pretzel.
So now we have this almost embarrassment of
riches where we have a lot of therapies,
and we still probably need help on how to best
deploy those for patients that are in front of us.
So if you look at
just these recently approved bladder-sparing
treatments, so Pembrolizumab, 41% complete response
rate.
When you use Adstiladrin, the intravesical adenoviral
therapy, a little shorter duration, 53% complete response
rate for CIS at three months. The Anctiva is the
IL-15 agonist at 71%, very gaudy
numbers here. And then, of course,
TAR200, the intravesical gemcitabine pretzel, again has a very
high complete response rate.
That's the leading
edge. Now we're getting to these other types of therapies.
So an oncolytic adenovirus CG007-0,
the genome is designed so that it can't
bind RB. And so if RB is lost,
like it is typically in high-grade carcinoma, the virus will actually replicate.
So you get an amplification of the initial dose.
The virus spreads to other cells and starts to eliminate
those cells as well. In addition, it expresses GM-CSF to have
innate immune activation.
EG70,
it's actually a plasmid that's delivered with a lipid nanoparticle that
activates both the adaptive and immune arms of the immune system as,
again, another
form of immunotherapy. And now
Janssen has the same pretzel that they put gemcitabine in,
but now they're actually putting an FGFR3 inhibitor, their drug ertifinib.
And that's going to be probably more of a personalized medicine because you have to
have FGFR3 to enter into those trials.
Okay. I'll just plug this
paper here. But again, Ashish,
very much a thought leader here.
Summary, so every time that IBCG meets, they have a white
paper that describes the things that they talk about.
And so one of the things that I've alluded to already is
how do you
choose what therapy in
the context of what the patient's need is, right?
Would they benefit from bladder-sparing therapy, or maybe are they going to benefit
more from cystectomy? And that's, of course, a very personal decision.
How many therapies is someone willing to tolerate?
Some patients don't tolerate intravesical therapy very well, and these things are
often given in repeated
manner over the course of many months or even years.
What are the side effects of the drugs, whether they're intravesical or systemic?
Anxiety, these things,
you go to the doctor's office, you have to get things put into your urethra.
It's a very private type of therapy.
These are all things that we have to consider
for the patient in front of us and how to really get to
the best therapy for the patient. And this
completely neglects any of the molecular subtyping that I
mentioned where if we had a test that says, "This patient
should get drug X, this one should get drug Y," that might simplify things a little
bit. And then the financial toxicity, which we'll talk about here
next.
These therapies are all
very expensive. So this is some work that
Ashish is doing. Please don't post this, but this is just
a summary, and you can see this left half of the
table here, the cost of these drugs over the course of five years
approaches three-quarters of a million dollars.
And you can use a Markov model, and we're doing some of this in my lab as
well. But this ICER is an incremental
cost-effectiveness ratio, which basically tells you, so that's the number of
dollars that
essentially buy you another quality
life year. So for TAR200,
that'sIf I'm reading that right, $20 million for one
additional life year. So these things are expensive
and the effectiveness, as you can see in the
fifth column there,
they're all fairly similarly effective.
And so,
especially with our,
I won't get too into the political, but all the budget stuff that we're going
through now,
we might get to a point where we have to make some decisions about what is actually
an affordable and a reasonable therapy.
So I'll talk now about just what we hope is coming in the
next-- and this thing probably I'm most excited about for the next decade is this
molecular stratification. These clinical
parameters that we use that I mentioned on the first couple slides,
the pathological stage, the number of recurrences, the
multifocality, the size of the tumor, those things are very crude measurements.
We can get maybe a little bit more risk stratification and
also to the point of predictive therapy potentially with
RNA expression profiles or other genetic alterations.
Number two, I'm also very excited about, that's what my lab really works on, is
this liquid biopsy
as a surveillance or predictive prognosticating
tool. So FGFR3 mutation is sort of
the
poster child here because of erdafitinib and other
FGFR3 targeted therapies. But there's a
lot more to come and there's things that we're working on in our lab as well.
We'll have a poster about that later.
And then I think just as important as these new therapies is
maybe you don't need a new therapy, and this is where liquid
biopsy can maybe tell patients or their
providers
when enough is enough, and you've done what we need to do, and we can
pause for a little bit and give patients a little bit of a reprieve.
And then
FGFR3 precision
personalized therapies as well as other things as they come out,
other targeted therapies that
can be given to a patient in
a more personalized method based on their genomic profile of the tumor.
So
this is obviously, I've tried to allude to this, this should really all be
very patient centric as we go through, and I think this is a good place to shout
out to organizations like BCAN, which the three of us are all
very closely intertwined with. The IBCG,
which Ashish and others started and I think is a really positive
force in bladder cancer, and then the World Bladder Cancer Patient Coalition.
These, again, are very patient-centered organizations trying to help
us make sense of what to do next. So here,
this is kind of an open call for membership to IBCG.
The mission here is both to improve the outcomes for patients
and then educate patients and providers with
what to do and how to do it. This group started in
and has grown
quite a few,
and maybe some of these faces are in the audience.
So again, open call for
membership. And with that, I'll pause, and I think we're going to take questions at
the end. Okay. So thank you.
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Abbosh. This was an excellent overview.
So next, we have Dr. Galsky. It's my pleasure
to introduce Matt. He's a medical oncologist
with a clinical and research focus on bladder
cancer. His pioneering research has centered on
approaches to escalate and deescalate treatments based on
response adaptive treatment paradigms.
He is currently the Lillian and Howard Stratton Professor of Medicine
at the Icahn School of Medicine at Mount Sinai and Deputy
Director of the Mount Sinai Tisch Cancer Center.
So with that, Matt, we're looking forward to your talk.
Thank you. And so I'm going to talk about muscle-invasive bladder
cancer. Here are my disclosures.
And I suspect there's some differences in familiarity with bladder
cancer among those in the audience, so I'm going to start from the
basics here and present a patient vignette, which I think
highlights some of the key points about muscle-invasive bladder cancer.
So our patient's an 80-year-old man, and he presents with gross
hematuria, that's blood in his urine, with no pain.
He presents to his primary care doctor, and his primary care
doctor astutely recognizes that blood in the urine in
an older patient is cancer until proven
otherwise. So he orders a CAT scan, and you can see the CAT scan.
I don't know if I can show-- Does my arrow show up? Yeah.
So you can see that there's bladder wall thickening.
This is suspicious for a bladder tumor.
So he's referred to a urologist, and the urologist places
a fiber optic scope into the bladder in the office,
a cystoscope, and is able to visualize the inner lining of the
bladder, sees a tumor there, and then schedules the patient to go
to the operating room for a rigid scope through which
instruments can be placed. And you can see the scope here.
You can see a bladder tumor, and you see the resection loop here.
And this procedure is called a TURBT
or transurethral resection of bladder tumor.
This procedure is sometimes a therapeutic procedure, but it's always a
diagnostic procedure. And this helps us define the
clinical stage of the disease, and you can see we just heard from Dr.
Abbosh about non-muscle invasive bladder cancer, Ta and T1
tumors. T2 tumors are when the cancer involves the muscularis
propria. That's muscle-invasive bladder cancer.
And our ability to distinguish clinical T2, T3, and
T4 cancers is somewhat challenging.
Clinical staging of bladder cancer is difficult, but we can tell
if someone has muscle-invasive disease based on
thatTransurethral resection specimen So our
patient asks his urologist what he should do, and
he's told that he should have his bladder removed surgically, a
cystectomy
in an ileal conduit diversion. Of course, when the bladder, the reservoir for
urine, is removed, the urine needs to be diverted, and so
this procedure involves urine draining externally to a bag, to an
ostomy. Radiation therapy is another standard treatment for bladder
cancer. I'm not going to talk about that today just because of lack of time.
So with cystectomy alone, this is a curative
intent surgery for muscle-invasive bladder cancer and cures
many patients, and is a backbone of treatment for muscle-invasive bladder
cancer. But you can see here that the likelihood of cure is very
much dependent on the pathological stage of disease.
So if under the microscope, when the bladder's removed, the cancer is
indeed organ confined, it's indeed pathological T2,
then outcomes are pretty good. But once you have T3 or T4
cancers or microscopic lymph node involvement, the risk of
metastatic recurrence gets much higher.
And historically or traditionally, we've quoted in all comers
with muscle-invasive bladder cancer, approximately 50%
chance of metastatic recurrence with surgery.
So this can be an aggressive disease.
And this vignette really highlights why muscle-invasive bladder
cancer decision-making is complicated.
Our patients are generally older.
The median age of diagnosis in the United States is 76.
Surgery can be life-altering. And despite surgery, there's
a high risk of metastatic recurrence.
And it's really that last point that has led
oncologists, clinical researchers, urologic
oncologists to try and integrate systemic therapy into the
management of muscle-invasive bladder cancer.
And on the somewhat disappointing side,
all of the advances in integrating systemic therapy in
muscle-invasive bladder cancer are essentially encompassed on this single slide.
On the positive slide, many of these advances have occurred in just the past
few years, and so that's really what I'm going to focus on today.
But just a little bit of a historical note.
Multi-agency cisplatin-based chemotherapy shown to be active in patients with
metastatic bladder cancer in the 1980s, integrated
into the neoadjuvant setting, so that's the pre-surgical setting prior
to cystectomy. Around that time, phase two studies showed
promise. Ultimately, phase three studies performed, and then
SWOG 8710, published in 2003, showing a
survival benefit with cisplatin-based chemotherapy prior to surgery.
And that's really what we had for about 30 years with few
advances. And it's not until the era of immune checkpoint
blockade that things really started to change.
And immune checkpoint blockade has many
points of significance in bladder cancer.
Certainly, there's scientific and clinical significance, but there's actually a lot
of practical significance because during these 30 years when
not a whole lot of developments were occurring, there was a lot of
pessimism about drug development in urothelial cancer.
There was this notion that we couldn't accrue trials, that patients were too sick,
that nothing worked. And that created a vicious cycle, and then there was lack
of funding. And really, immune checkpoint blockade showing activity
early in the phase one studies in urothelial cancer started to
open the floodgates of interest really across the board.
And so this represents a turning point.
And in metastatic disease, single agent
PD-1 or PD-L1 blockade has a response rate of about
25%. So it doesn't work in everyone, but of course, like in other
solid tumors, when those drugs work, they work quite well.
And so the logical step of integrating immune checkpoint blockade in
muscle-invasive bladder cancer was to test these therapies in the
adjuvant setting, that is, after patients have surgery
and have features suggestive of a high risk for metastatic
recurrence under the microscope.
And three studies were launched at around the same time, almost
identically designed with a few nuances. The three studies are shown here.
All of them compared a year of immune checkpoint blockade to either
observation or placebo, similar endpoints.
And interestingly, two of the studies met their primary
endpoints, showing an improvement in disease-free survival. One of them didn't.
The study with atezolizumab didn't, but I'm going to circle back to that because
it's been a very important study for the field.
CheckMate 274, which showed an improvement in disease-free
survival with nivolumab, is the only one that's led to an FDA approval
in this space.
So here's the DFS curves with adjuvant nivolumab.
Clearly, this has been an advance in the field integrated into standard
care. But the benefit of nivolumab in the adjuvant setting
is limited by the
challenges of adjuvant therapy for solid tumors
in general, which is that when we give adjuvant therapy, of
course, this is really the only setting in cancer where we're giving
drugs with a relatively narrow therapeutic index to patients who actually don't
have cancer. You can see here, of course, patients treated with
placebo
who are cured with surgery, with or without neoadjuvant therapy.
So these patients don't need treatment.
We could give them all the treatment that we want, and we can only
worsen their outcomes from the standpoint of toxicity.
Of course, these patients in between these lines need treatment and benefit
from it, and the patients above the nivo curve
need adjuvant treatment, but they don't benefit.
And so one would be hard-pressed to find a setting where we need biomarkers
more than we need in the adjuvant setting.
And I say biomarkers rather than biomarker because I think
we have a double biomarker problem in the adjuvant setting.
We have a single biomarker problem in the metastatic setting, arguably.
We have a bunch of drugs. We don't know which patients respond to which drugs, and
we need biomarkers to determine the right drugs for the right patient.In
the adjuvant setting, we have this double problem.
Not only don't we know what drugs work for which patients, we don't even
really know who needs treatment. And this gets conflated because, of
course, you can't benefit from treatment if you don't need treatment, but you
can need treatment and not benefit from it.
And so I would argue that we need two sets of biomarkers to answer these
questions. I don't think they're necessarily going to be the same.
Finding biomarkers to determine who benefits from particular drugs
has been a little bit more elusive, but we're getting much closer to
defining who needs treatment in the adjuvant setting.
And of course, what's been most promising has been cfDNA
as a measure of minimal residual disease.
So I told you that that study with atezolizumab in IMvigor10 didn't
meet its primary endpoint, and so the investigators
did a molecular autopsy of that study, if you will, and they asked the
question, would the results have been different if they were able to
determine who actually needed adjuvant treatment?
So they applied a tumor-informed ctDNA test, the Signatera assay,
retrospectively to this study. And now you see the disease-free
survival curves, and here's patients with undetectable ctDNA at a
single time point after cystectomy.
Here's patients with detectable ctDNA.
And you see here now there seems to be a benefit from atezolizumab
in blue versus observation in red.
So this is retrospective data, of course.
And what these investigators did is really how this should work, a
negative study trying to dissect why the study
didn't turn out positive, and then designing a study to test that
concept. And so that's just what they did, and they did a prospective
study seeking to determine whether or not ctDNA
would have changed the results. And so the design was almost
identical to IMvigor10. This is IMvigor11.
But what they did here was enroll patients after surgery, similar
pathologic features under the microscope, and patients underwent
ctDNA testing. And if they had detectable ctDNA,
they were randomized to atezolizumab versus placebo.
And if they had undetectable ctDNA, then they had serial
testing every six weeks for a year.
And if at any time the test converted from
undetectable to detectable, then they entered the randomization.
And I should mention that same assay, Signatera
tumor-informed testing. Interestingly, the study was designed
to test whether or not atezo led to an improvement in
outcomes compared to placebo in patients with
ctDNA detectable assays, regardless of when that occurred,
either immediately after surgery in the traditional adjuvant setting or
during that year of surveillance.
So all that data was pooled, but then they analyzed the population
separately as well. So here's the flow of patients in that study.
Six hundred and seven patients. Four hundred and fifty-nine had undetectable
assays after surgery. Among those during that follow-up,
22% had conversion from undetectable to
detectable. So an undetectable test right after
surgery, unfortunately, with the assays currently available, certainly doesn't
mean that patients are "out of the woods."
But thankfully, only 4% of patients on this
study during that follow-up developed metastatic disease
on scan prior to an assay converting from
negative to positive or undetectable to detectable, suggesting that
there is potentially this window of opportunity for intervention
before detecting radiographic metastatic disease.
And here's the outcomes on the study.
The top are patients who had detectable ctDNA right after surgery.
The bottom are patients who had detectable ctDNA sometime during that
follow-up. You see that disease-free survival and overall
survival improved in both of those populations
with atezolizumab versus placebo.
And so this study's important for a number of reasons.
One, because it prospectively validates the findings from
IMvigor10 and establishes clinical utility.
I think one of the first demonstrations of clinical utility
for ctDNA in terms of adjuvant decision-making.
And second, I think this is probably the first
demonstration that molecular recurrence of bladder
cancer is a clinically intervenable disease
state that can lead to improvement in outcomes.
And obviously, this has implications for drug development as well.
In the US Cooperative Group System, we've taken
a slightly different approach to this question, arguing that
nivolumab was already approved by the FDA for adjuvant therapy.
And if you look at those survival curves
with adjuvant atezolizumab in patients with detectable
ctDNA, obviously, we have to do better than that.
And so we're asking two questions in this study called MODERN.
We're asking an escalation question and a de-escalation
question. And the way this trial works, patients are enrolled
after cystectomy, similar pathological features to the other
studies. They undergo Signatera testing, tumor-informed
ctDNA testing. If they have detectable ctDNA,
they're randomized to nivolumab versus nivolumab plus a
LAG-3 inhibitor, so seeking to escalate treatment.
This part of the study employs a seamless Phase 2, 3 design, and
the Phase 2 endpoint is ctDNA clearance.
So we hope to establish perhaps the first time that we can use ctDNA
clearance as a way to screen the activity of novel regimens in the adjuvant
setting. And in patients with undetectable ctDNA, we're
asking, is a surveillance, a watch-and-wait
approach with treatment upon molecular recurrence
non-inferior to immediate adjuvant treatment in all?
So this has been enrolling for about two years, and is
open throughout the United States.While this is occurring in the
adjuvant setting, of course, drug development continues in the metastatic setting,
and we heard already from Dr. Faltes about the combination of enfortumab
vedotin and pembrolizumab. So this is an antibody drug conjugate
directed against nectin-4 with an MMAE payload
combined with PD-1 blockade. In the metastatic setting,
results in response rates of about 60% to 70%,
really the highest that we've seen in urothelial cancer.
A blue platinum-based chemotherapy out of the water in a phase
three study that was presented in 2023 and really
has become the standard of care for metastatic urothelial
cancer. And of course, the logical thing is then to take that regimen and
apply it to the muscle-invasive bladder cancer setting.
So that's been done in two studies now, one study in patients
who were considered ineligible to receive cisplatin-based chemotherapy,
the only perioperative systemic therapy that has shown benefit
historically. So that randomization was EV pembro,
followed by cystectomy, followed by adjuvant EV pembro
versus cystectomy alone, and then
KEYNOTE-B15 compared neoadjuvant cisplatin-based
chemotherapy to this perioperative EV pembro
approach,
and both of the studies have now read out over the last year.
You can see the event-free survival curves, the primary endpoint of the
study at the bottom, and you see that both studies show a marked
improvement in outcomes with EV pembro in the perioperative setting
versus either cisplatin-based neoadjuvant therapy or cystectomy
alone, depending on the study. And then here you see the pathological
response rates on the study.
So cystectomy alone, a path CR rate, meaning that, of
course, when the bladder's removed and analyzed under the microscope, there's no
evidence of cancer under the microscope.
So with cystectomy alone, there's about a 9% chance of that
happening. How does that happen? Well, remember I told you that transurethral
resection is performed. Sometimes that gets rid of all the
cancer. So about a 9% chance with cystectomy
alone, but 57.1% path CR rate with EV
pembro, very similar in KEYNOTE-B15 and much better
than older chemotherapy. So when we see a path
CR in the clinic, as medical oncologists, we're quite happy to see
it. It correlates with better survival.
You can see in the curves here.
And of course, patients look at us like we're crazy when we say, "Great
news, there's no cancer in your bladder," after their bladder has already been
removed. And so that really begs the question, what's happening?
And who are these patients in this top curve here?
And I would argue that there's three groups of patients, right?
There are these patients who have local disease and micrometastatic
disease that's eradicated with systemic therapy.
There's patients who have no micrometastatic disease but have local disease that's
eradicated.
And then there is that group of patients where the systemic therapy did nothing and
the transurethral resection got rid of local tumor.
Regardless of how this is achieved, if TURBT
plus systemic therapy can get rid of muscle-invasive bladder cancer,
then can this be an effective standard treatment for
muscle-invasive bladder cancer?
And that's a question that's been sort of bandied about in the
field for 30 plus years. We started thinking about this, the Fox
Chase group started thinking about this probably about 12 years ago
in a more serious way to really try and dissect what are the
barriers to achieving this in the clinic.
And we outlined these five barriers to implementation of
TURBT plus systemic therapy as curative
bladder-sparing treatment for muscle-invasive bladder cancer.
One, we really didn't have prospective studies. That's the biggest barrier.
The second is that this notion of a clinical response to treatment
had never been really defined. What assessments are needed?
What is a clinical complete response?
Our systemic therapies were suboptimal, of course.
And then there's this limited understanding of what happens with
a delayed cystectomy. So if a patient achieves a, quote-unquote, clinical complete
response, and their bladder's left intact, and they have a later local
recurrence and require cystectomy, have we missed a window of
opportunity for a cure? And then absence of biomarkers to
refine decision-making. So over the past decade, I think we're
making a lot of progress in the first three, and we're making some
progress in the last two, and I'm going to touch on this during the remainder.
So our first trial at attempting to determine whether or not this was a
viable strategy, we designed in 2016.
In this study, patients with muscle-invasive bladder cancer got four cycles
of chemotherapy plus PD-1 blockade and then underwent a
series of assessments, including repeat cystoscopy and biopsies
of the bladder. And if all of those assessments showed no evidence of
cancer, patients had the choice to have no cystectomy and receive
additional maintenance immune checkpoint blockade or to have a
cystectomy. If there was no clinical complete response, then we
recommended proceeding with standard cystectomy.
The co-primary endpoints were to define the clinical complete response rate because
clinical complete response had never been defined before, and to determine
the performance of a clinical complete response in
predicting longer-term outcomes.
So 76 patients enrolled on this study.
The clinical complete response rate was 43%.
You can see here that among 33 patients with a clinical CR,
only one opted for immediate cystectomy.
Patients voted with their feet here.
And here you see the outcomes on this study.
So here's metastasis-free survival stratified by clinical
complete response.At the landmark time point of clinical restaging.
If nothing else, clinical complete response is a prognostic
biomarker here. So really separates patients at higher
versus lower risk of developing metastatic disease.
And in these swimmer's lane plots, these are the 33 patients with a clinical
complete response. The dark blue indicates their bladder's intact
with no evidence of recurrence. The light blue indicates they
ultimately needed a cystectomy. Red indicates local
recurrence, yellow indicates cystectomy, and then purple
indicates metastatic recurrence, which occurred in two patients
here. So we think that a subset of patients can be cured
with TURBT plus systemic therapy, but of course, we
need to do a little bit better here.
So how do we improve this paradigm?
Well, one, we develop treatments that work better and are applicable to a
larger subset of patients. And then, of course, the other is to
discover biomarkers to refine decision-making.
So here again, cfDNA, very low-hanging fruit.
This is a perfect application of cfDNA.
So we took samples from this study, and we tested
ctDNA at serial time points,
using the V96 assay in collaboration with Dr.
Bert Vogelstein. This involves whole genome sequencing of
tumor and matched blood,
and then selection of up to 96 mutations per patient.
And then a number of approaches to reduce error, including
duplex sequencing. We had a single time point of
urine collected here, and one might think that urine is even more
important than blood here, because what we're really trying to do is determine
whether or not we can detect subclinical residual disease in the
bladder. So here's the ctDNA results, and I'm just going to call
your attention to these pie charts here.
So this is baseline ctDNA in patients who achieved a
clinical complete response versus those who didn't.
Red indicates detectable ctDNA. So for starters,
you're more likely to achieve a clinical CR if you have undetectable baseline
ctDNA, probably not that surprising.
Interestingly though, at the time of restaging,
100% of patients who had a clinical CR have undetectable
ctDNA. That's absolutely what you would want to see, and
we've replicated this in another study.
So ctDNA is a way to help refine decision-making here.
We don't think it's actually that helpful because everyone has undetectable
ctDNA. It's actually the patients who don't have a clinical CR,
where it's more interesting. So these patients have biopsy-proven
residual disease in their bladder, and all of these patients
underwent cystectomy, and if you underwent cystectomy
with detectable ctDNA prior to cystectomy, you can really
identify patients who are still going to be cured with surgery versus
not. Perhaps these patients don't need surgery, they need
something else. Just one more slide and then I'm going to wrap up.
So here's the urine, and the urine tells the completely opposite
story. So here's utDNA at the time of
restaging in patients who did not have a clinical complete response.
Virtually everyone has detectable urine tumor DNA.
Here's the urine tumor DNA in patients with a clinical CR, and
remember, these patients have negative urine cytology,
negative blind biopsies of the bladder, negative
imaging. Half of the patients almost have detectable urine tumor
DNA, and those patients who elect to not have their
bladders removed, if you stratify them by utDNA,
you can really determine who is at risk for local
recurrence and ultimate cystectomy versus not.
So,
the other approach, obviously, to improve this treatment paradigm is better
treatments and low-hanging fruit, of course, integrating atezolizumab and
bevacizumab into this paradigm. We just finished a study doing this.
Industry has launched a large study doing this.
Always nice to see large industry efforts that are trying to
further expand concepts that might ultimately lead to regulatory
approval. And so, to finish up, this is our future vision of
muscle-invasive bladder cancer. This is our current paradigm.
Everyone gets neoadjuvant treatment who's eligible for it.
Everyone gets cystectomy. We think we can do things in a much more rational way.
Maybe we're not ready for pre-treatment biomarkers yet. Those have been elusive.
But trying to capitalize on the information that we obtain during a
patient's treatment seems to be lower-hanging fruit in terms of
individualizing care. So clinical restaging,
ctDNA, utDNA, guiding various treatment paths.
I'd like to just acknowledge everyone who's been involved in this work at Sinai,
our collaborators at Hopkins, Dr.
Faltas, and funding agencies, and thank you.
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Galsky. This was a tour de force.
So if you're just joining us, my name is Basoy Faltas.
I'm a medical oncologist at Weill Cornell Medicine.
And what I'm
going to share with you today is how we're thinking in my lab
about addressing two important unmet clinical needs.
I will focus on two themes today. First, modeling therapy
resistance to identify new targetable mechanisms,
and second, I will show you how we're utilizing window of
opportunity and co-clinical trial designs for developing
rational sequential combinations for patients with bladder
cancer.As you've heard from Dr.
Abash and Dr. Galsky, we now have a number of effective
therapies for non-invasive, muscle-invasive, and metastatic bladder
cancer. And despite these major advances,
resistance remain a key unmet need in patients with bladder cancer.
Unfortunately, so I'll start with a clinical scenario as well.
So this is a common clinical scenario that we often see in clinic.
This is a patient with metastatic bladder cancer treated with first-line
therapy. And as you can see, the cancer initially responds only
to relapse despite continued treatment in just
sometimes a matter of a few weeks.
And in many of these cases, it's our practice and in many
other tertiary cancer centers,
the practice is to obtain next generation whole
exome or targeted sequencing of the tumor.
And when we receive, in many cases, when we get back that genetic
sequencing report, there are no clear driver mutations that are
driving the resistance. So what's going on there?
So, and we decided to try to
model drug resistance to recapitulate the clinical
scenario. But how can we do that? So we think there are four key
elements. First, scale. A patient with a one
centimeter tumor in diameter has close to a billion
cancer cells in their body. So our system has to have a similar
scale to capture the clonal evolution dynamics of these rare
resistant clones.
Second, we need sustained drug pressure over clinically relevant
timescales. Usually, these are measured in weeks to month to mirror the
time it takes for resistance to develop in the clinic.
Third, a closed system that enables,
essentially, that resistance to develop without additional
unnecessary perturbations to the system,
and that introduce artificial or artifacts in terms
of evolutionary bottlenecks. And finally, we need the resolution to
resolve clonal selection over time at the single-cell level,
so we can recapitulate minimal residual disease dynamics in
the clinic,
where relapse often starts, as you've heard from Dr.
Galsky and Dr. Abash, from just a few cancer cells that is
what's underlying this ctDNA or cfDNA.
So to capture these elements, we developed a system that we call
Evolutionary Single-Cell Genomics RNA and Lineage Tracking
system, or Evo Signals for short. This is a platform that
combines several other technologies.
It's constant drug selection of more than a billion cancer cells.
The cells are labeled with heritable antiviral barcodes that track the
emergence of drug resistance over time.
These are cell tag barcodes that are developed by Sam Morris's
group, and these are transcribable and heritable antiviral
barcodes. Because they are transcribable, we can perform single-cell
RNA sequencing to discover gene expression changes in the
clonally expansive populations.
These cells are also serially imaged over time to detect any
morphological changes.
One of the main questions that we developed Evo Signals to investigate
is to dissect how cancer heterogeneity acts as a
precursor to therapy resistance.
And in my lab, we focus on the APOBEC family of mutagenic
cytidine deaminases that are a common source of genetic
heterogeneity in bladder cancer.
We recently showed that APOBEC-3 activity in bladder cancer is
early and clonal, arising before exposure to
systemic therapy. And you can appreciate this in this phylogenetic tree
that's reconstructed from the primary and the metastatic tumors from a rapid
autopsy of a patient with bladder cancer at Weill
Cornell. And you can see on the right that this was also
quantified across all patients in the cohort and confirms
that APOBEC activity is early and clonal.
So again, before the patient sees any treatment, there's a lot of APOBEC
activity.
So we hypothesized that this early APOBEC-3A, or A3A for
short, which I'll refer to by A3 in the rest of the talk,
this induced heterogeneity by A3A drives therapy resistance.
So to model this, we
used a cell line called a 5637 bladder cancer cell line with
a doxycycline-inducible A3A expression vector, and
we established isogenic clones exposed to six cycles of
doxycycline to induce A3A or DMSO controls,
which were then labeled with the cell tag barcodes.
And the 5637 line harbors an ERBB2
S310F activating mutation, so it shows initial
sensitivity to the tyrosine kinase inhibitor neratinib.
So we used continuous neratinib treatment on these
cells for 35 days. Again, there's no trypsinization or any other
perturbation as a selective pressure that is applied to one
billion A3A-exposed and isogenic control cells in our Evo
Signal system.
And what we saw is that the A3A-exposed cells were significantly more
resistant, showing higher survival after 35 days in
continuous neratinib and a 4.8-fold higher
IC50 to neratinib from the cells that are
graduating from the system.
And moreover, we observed that the A3A-exposed clones
significantly expand during therapy, more the controls.
And we know this from reconstructing the clonal relationships between
different cells using the cell tag barcodes, which is what you're seeing here.
So this is an actual lineage of these cells that have gone through
this treatment. And you can see here is that the A3A-exposed lineages
also had more founder cell nodes and more descendants per
founder, suggesting both greater initial heterogeneity
and greater clonal expansion of the descendants from each
cell.The A3A exposed cells were
also found to be multi-drug resistant, so resistant to other
drugs that they have not been exposed to before, including the HER2
targeting antibody drug conjugate decitabine vedotin, FGFR3
inhibitors such as erdafitinib and infigratinib.
And we also confirmed these results in a patient-derived bladder cancer
organoid model that we've established, which showed resistance to
enfortumab vedotin after A3A exposure.
So we then asked, what is the mechanism underlying this multi-drug
resistant state? And because we can directly track
these clonally expansive populations, so the population that gave rise to
descendants over time using the Cell Takt barcodes,
and as I mentioned to you earlier, these are transcribable barcodes.
So we can then use single-cell RNA sequencing to interrogate the underlying
resistance mechanisms that are linked to these barcodes and
compare these mechanisms between the A3A exposed and control
populations.
So the gene set enrichment analysis of the single-cell
transcriptomes of these expansive A3A exposed clones
showed significant enrichment of epithelial-to-mesenchymal plasticity
programs compared to the controls in a number of other pathways that you can see
here. And we try to understand what
are the transcription factors that probably drive some of these
changes. And we performed a transcription factor targeted analysis
that nominated several important transcription factors that you can
see here, including SOX2, as differentially
upregulated in the A3A exposed cells.
Now, SOX2 piqued our interest. As many of you know, SOX2 is a
master regulator of self-renewal, pluripotency,
and undifferentiated states. In fact, it's one of the
Yamanaka factors that can reprogram a differentiated cell into
a pluripotent
stem cell state, and it is involved in several cancer hallmarks,
including plasticity, invasion, and metastasis.
So how does A3A upregulate exposure to
SOX2?
So our hypothesis was that A3A induced
DNA damage as the initiating stimulus for SOX2-driven
plasticity, and A3A induces DNA damage or double-strand
breaks in a number of different ways, one of which is inducing
continuous replication stress and double-strand DNA breaks.
And what we saw here is transient. So short-term A3A exposure for
24 hours include increased markers of replication stress,
dramatically markers of double-stranded DNA breaks, and
including γH2AX and phosphorylated
RPA32, which is a marker of single-stranded DNA accumulation.
Cell cycle analysis that you can see on the right shows that even transient
A3A exposure prolonged the S to G2
transition, causing cells to enter a state of what we call late
S phase stasis.
So we then asked, can this transient A3A exposure is
sufficient to induce lasting changes in the cell?
So can we turn off A3A and then continue to see these changes?
And we exposed these 5637 cells to 48 hours of A3A
expression, withdrew doxycycline, and then monitored cell cycle
dynamics and vimentin levels for 168
hours after dox withdrawal. And as you can see, the cells
continue to upregulate markers of plasticity, such as vimentin,
and to have markers of this persistent S-phase stasis for a
number of hours after we withdraw A3A.
Okay, so now we know that A3A induces double-strand
breaks in S-phase stasis, but what is the mechanistic link
between these processes and SOX2 upregulation?
Is it a state of A3A chromatin remodeling,
perhaps, or is it another transcription factor that
upregulates SOX2? And to answer this, we performed chromatin
accessibility profiling, so ATAC-seq on these 5637 cells
after either one cycle, so one exposure or six
transient exposures of A3A. And
on the left, you can see the tornado plot that shows the A3A persistent
changes in chromatin accessibility profiles in both conditions,
suggesting that these accessibility changes are maintained across cell
divisions. And we saw that there is a marked increase
in chromatin accessibility at the SOX2 promoter.
And we asked, well, what is another transcription factor that
might be binding to the SOX2 promoter that is upregulated by
A3A double-strand breaks and cell cycle stasis?
And the answer is FOXM1. And to us, this
made sense because FOXM1 is a master regulator
of the DNA damage repair response.
It increases during the S phase. So that made sense to us.
And indeed, when we looked at our ChIP-qPCR experiment here, we
see an 11-fold higher FOXM1 occupancy at the SOX2
promoter in the A3A exposed cells, but not in the controls.
And we can see that this goes away when we use a DMNA stead
E72A mutant of A3A.
We also clearly confirmed this at the protein level.
So again, here you can look at the 5637 cell line and a breast cancer cell
line, and you can see that A3A exposure increases
FOXM1, SOX2, and vimentin at the protein level.
Interestingly, we observed this wasn't the only change in the
regulatory regions of SOX2. We also saw a marked increase in
chromatin accessibility at a SOX2 distal super enhancer
element that's previously shown to be necessary and sufficient for
SOX2 expression.And we know that
SOX2 acts as its own transcription factor, so it
sustains its own expression by binding directly to its
own enhancer to reinforce transcription, and this cooperates
with the persistent changes in chromatin accessibility at the SOX2
promoter and distal enhancer to lock
these A3A-exposed cells into this stable
SOX2 high state independent of any ongoing A3A
activity.
So, one could say, well, this is all with
exogenously expressed A3A. This is quite artificial.
And we can know we can induce endogenous A3A with interferon.
And when we did that, we can see that we can also upregulate SOX2 in
multiple cell lines, and when we knock out A3A with CRISPR,
that this effect completely is really abrogated.
And importantly, when we overexpressed a deaminase
dead E72A
mutant, A3A mutant, we see that the SOX2 and the FOXM1
downstream effects are not seen, suggesting that the
deaminase activity of A3A is required.
So to put all that together, we coined a term for this state, which we
call DASP or deaminase activated cell cycle
stasis and reprogramming. And this is our proposed model
for the sequence of molecular events that occur in DASP.
First, the A3A deaminase activity generates
double-strand breaks, inducing cell cycle stasis in the late S phase,
and this opens a permissive temporal window for chromatin
remodeling at the SOX2 locus, increasing accessibility
at both the proximal promoter and the distal enhancer, as I showed
you. FOXM1 binds to the SOX2 promoter and directly
activates transcription, while the distal enhancer provides
additional transactivation. And this establishes
a feed-forward circuit that locks the cells into this
SOX2 high state.
And one of the interesting aspects of DASP that I want to highlight is that it
shows us that it's a mechanism by which a transient
genotoxic stress or double-strand break caused by A3A can be
converted into a heritable long-lasting cell state with
important phenotypic consequences, as I will show you in a minute.
So what are these functional consequences?
One of them is one that I showed you already, which is drug resistance,
where you can see that these cancer cells that are exhibiting DASP
have a fitness advantage and survive better under
drug selection.
Another phenotype is increased migration, and we have measured
this with live-cell imaging that shows increased migration in the
5637 cells exposed to A3A compared to
controls.
And this one is my favorite. So this is live-cell imaging of
a 3D Matrigel spheroid invasion assay of a different cell line called
UMUC3 that is exposed to A3A, and
you can easily appreciate that by the end of the video, which is day
18, the A3A-exposed cells have
4.7 times larger invading
area compared to the controls.
And when we performed confocal microscopy of these
spheroids, we see that the cells at the invasive front
consistently show higher SOX2 expression and morphologically
are very different from the controls.
I was just telling Phil, if you look at the bottom, when I looked at these for the
first time, I thought that the scale bar was wrong, but it's not.
These are really morphologically very different, and they're quite
invasive as we are observing here.
So now that we have this new cell state,
one might ask, well, how do we know that this is truly a distinct reprogrammed
state and not just a generic cell stress response?
And to test this, we experimentally induced A3A,
treated the same cells, so other cells, same cell line,
but different treatment, with either doxorubicin to
induce DNA damage, tunicamycin to induce ER stress, or
TGF-beta, which is a canonical inducer of EMT.
And we performed RNA sequencing, and as you can see here,
the transcriptomes of the A3A-exposed cells clustered quite separately from
the other stress responses in the principal component analysis.
Importantly,
confirming the role of the FOXM1 SOX2 axis here, we can see that
A3A exposure is the only condition that co-activates both
FOXM1 and SOX2 targets.
And we further validated these results at the protein level by measuring
FOXM1 and SOX2 in cells exposed to either A3A,
doxorubicin, TGF-beta, or tunicamycin.
And again, DASP is the only state that upregulates both
FOXM1 and SOX2.
We developed a DASP transcriptomic signature to apply to clinical
samples that combine four gene sets that represents its
salient biological features, the SOX2 target genes,
FOXM1 target genes, S phase genes, and
epithelial-mesenchymal plasticity genes into
a single normalized enrichment score.
And when we applied this DASP score to the TGA pan-cancer
human atlas, we see that tumors with high A3A
mRNA expression had significantly higher DASP scores compared to
the A3A-low tumors and higher enrichment of the FOXM1
and SOX2 targets.
And patients with those tumors had higher DASP scores--
patients with tumors who have higher DASP scores have worse
progression-free survival to a number of therapies and worse overall
survival.So can we reverse this? And can we
target SOX2, which we again mentioned is an important
mediator here, to reverse DASP? And we tested a SOX2 by
PROTAC, which is a SOX2 binding nanobody
fused to a modified E3 ubiquitin ligase that selectively degrades
SOX2, and we can see that this sensitizes
A3 exposed cells to trastuzumab
deruxtecan, which is a HER2
targeting antibody drug conjugate with a
topoisomerase inhibitor payload.
So this demonstrates how SOX2 inhibition is a promising
strategy for reversing DASP mediated drug resistance.
Now I'll switch gears to the second part of my talk, which is how do we use window
of opportunity and co-clinical trial designs to identify
rational sequential drug combinations?
One of the questions that arises from having multiple effective
therapies is what is the best mechanistically grounded sequence for
these drugs?
We have developed a co-clinical trial framework that
allows us to define the biology of an initial therapy in
patients in a window of opportunity study design, and then
test rational sequential strategies in patient-derived
organoids from the same trial and from the same patients.
And I'll show you
an example of how we did this. So this is in CLONIVA,
which is an investigator initiated window of opportunity trial
that we completed at Weill Cornell, and it's in patients
with resectable muscle invasive bladder cancer who were cisplatin
ineligible or declined cisplatin.
These patients received four to eight weeks of oral abemaciclib, which is a
CDK4/6 inhibitor, and we collected paired pre and post-treatment
tissues from these patients with serial plasma samples.
We had 20 patients enrolled, 16 patients underwent cystectomy and
were evaluable for the primary endpoint.
And to define the biological effects and the therapeutic vulnerabilities that
arise from these effects, after abemaciclib treatment, we
performed whole exome sequencing, RNA sequencing, and spatial single-cell
imaging mass cytometry comparing the pre and post-treatment tissue
specimens. We also performed whole exome sequencing of the ctDNA
samples
from the plasma.
And what we saw here is that a short course of abemaciclib, of
single agent abemaciclib, achieved a 31% pathologic downstaging,
19% pathologic complete response rate, and ctDNA
reduction in 69% of these evaluable
patients. And what we found from the RNA sequencing of the
matched pre and post tissues was that there was significant downregulation
in the expression of genes involved in homologous recombination
repair of double stranded breaks after DNA damage.
We confirmed this with imaging mass cytometry, at the protein
level, showing that key homologous recombination proteins,
including RAD51 and TOPBP1, which is a scaffold
protein important for RAD51 loading,
significantly decrease after abemaciclib, suggesting that
abemaciclib might impair homologous recombination in cancer cells.
And this led us to test whether sequential combinations of CDK4/6
inhibitors can be used to impair DNA damage repair, and
augment ADCs. And we tested this
in multiple urothelial cancer cell lines and patient-derived
organoids. And what we can see here is that sequential
abemaciclib enhanced the cytotoxicity of a number of
ADCs, including trastuzumab deruxtecan
or T-DXd, which has a topoisomerase inhibitor payload,
docetaxib vedotin, and enfirtuximab vedotin, which both
have MMAE payloads.
And we then ask, can this strategy be extended to an EV
resistant disease? And we developed an EV resistant
patient-derived organoid model using,
that we call WCM748. And these were exposed to
increasing concentrations of EV.
And what we ended up with, approximately 30 fold more resistant to
EV compared to the parental line. And if you look at the Western blot on the
right, you can see that these cells downregulate nectin 4, which
is the target of EV, but maintain RAD51 and TOPBP1,
and also
maintain or even upregulate the other
ADC targets such as HER2.
And in this EV resistant model, we again see that sequential
CDK4/6 inhibition
after the HER2 targeted
ADC,
shows significant efficacy. And this supports
a mechanistic rationale for testing sequential
CDK4/6 inhibitors with ADCs in patients who
progress on EV.
So in conclusion,
we think that laboratory models that recapitulate the clinical
resistance scenarios are critical for defining mechanisms of
resistance. We think that this state called deaminase
activated cell cycle stasis and reprogramming provides a
new mechanistic angle for understanding how transient
genotoxic stress is converted into heritable long lasting
effects.
We see that DASP establishes a heritable adaptive cell state that
persists across cell divisions driven by chromatin remodeling and the
FOXM1 SOX2 axis, and is quite distinct from other
stress responses. And we can see that it leads to several
aggressive cancer phenotypes, and that we can reverse or
inhibit many of these phenotypes by targeting SOX2.
And finally, we think that this co-clinical trial platform with
patient-derived organoids can enable rational sequential drug
combinations in a much better
biologically informed way. And as I showed you,
we've presented some solid
data here showing thatThere is that abemaciclib, for
example, augments the cytotoxicity of several ADCs by
inhibiting DNA repair. And based on that, we propose clinical
trials of sequential combinations of CDK4/6
inhibitors with ADCs in EV-resistant
urothelial cancer.
So, I'm at the end of my talk, and all of this work
was led by two postdocs in the lab,
Rahul Singh and Mohammed Osman, with
contributions from many others, including Daiwan Xu, Soonho,
Abhishek, Paul, Michael, and Wei Ze.
And I want to thank my collaborators at Weill Cornell, Scott Tighe and Doug
Scherer, who supported the CLONEVA trial, our collaborators at Mount Sinai,
especially Matt Galsky and Polykarpos Poulakakos.
I want to thank the funding agencies and, most importantly, patients and their
families who enabled this work. And with that, happy to take
any questions.
So if you have a question for Dr. Abash, Dr.
Galsky, or myself, please come to the microphone and we'll
have a lively and interesting conversation.
Hi, this is Parminder from Mayo Clinic. Great talks, guys.
Really good to hear all this fascinating work, especially Bishoy.
I have two questions, one for Matt and one for Bishoy. I'll start off with Matt.
So Matt, if we think that ctDNA is a
good marker for minimal residual disease, so much so that if we
have an imaging test which is so refined that it could
detect that microscopic disease, for example, the PSMA
PET scans in prostate cancer picking up disease which was
not seen on CT or bone scan.
So if we have a patient with ctDNA positive and we
assume that this is minimal residual disease, would you consider a clinical
trial
with
more patients being randomized to immunotherapy versus
chemoimmunocombinations, which we know are better than immunotherapy alone?
Is it an equipoise enough to have a design like that?
Or you think that
because immunotherapy is proven to be inferior as a single agent versus
chemoimmunocombination like EV-pembro, that design would
not meet the benchmark for an
equipoise for randomization?
So I think as you know, and maybe some in the audience
know that with these approaches that integrate
enfortumab vedotin and pembrolizumab in the neoadjuvant setting,
that has implications in the adjuvant setting because patients are already
exposed to those drugs, and those regimens include an adjuvant component.
So the study that you're referring to, that's a pure adjuvant study
randomizing patients to
PD-1, PD-L1 blockade monotherapy versus a combination.
I think it's clearly a study that should be done,
and then the question is, from a practical standpoint, can it be done with the
changing landscape?
Based on our prior conversation, I would argue it probably could be done,
but it's more of a practical issue than a scientific issue.
Got it. And Bishoy, for you,
I was following your initial set of slides,
and you mentioned that as these cells
become resistant, and you showed testing against niraparib
and EV and dicetabine, and these are
drugs which are targeting HER2 or nectin-4.
And I didn't see that you mentioned that those A3A
exposed cell lines, they had those markers which could
potentially impact their response.
And you didn't show testing versus cisplatin or other agents
in those earlier slides. And I was not sure if I missed something there,
or was there something you were alluding to.
Why did you choose to test drugs which have more a precision
oncology element in it when testing, and
you didn't show that the markers were there on those resistance cell lines?
Yeah. So Parminder, that's an excellent question.
So when we started doing this, I've had, as you
know, some experience with looking at cisplatin resistance for a long time, and
I've sort of know that these drugs where
the mechanism is not targeted, as you
mentioned, so that was a bit intentional.
It's a bit hard to go back and identify any resistance mechanisms.
So initially, my hypothesis was that if we go with a
targeted drug, that it would be a lot more tractable to
identify what happened, because in a way that you
can go back and look at it. You
know where to look, essentially. However, to our surprise,
this phenotype that is induced by transin A3A
exposure is truly multi-drug resistant, and
it's truly a changed state
that is very different from sort of what I had
initially set out to explore, what I expected would happen.
And in my mind at least, that makes sense that it
is induced by these two transcription
factors that change a lot more in the cell,
more than essentially one single targeted mutation.
So that is why we looked at that. However, we did check to make
sure that each, for example, that we're treating a cell that
expresses HER2 with T-DXd or express a
nectin-4 with EV and so on. So we know that those drugs are
acting on target.
Thank you.
Hi. A question about the ctDNA
study from Dr. Galsky. When you were looking at urine versus blood,
did you do a head-to-head comparison of the sensitivity of ctDNA in
urine versus blood? And in general, could you comment on
Whether it's even worthwhile to do blood testing in bladder cancer
versus just going right to the source and doing urine.
So maybe I'll answer the second part first.
Yeah, I think it's absolutely necessary because there are patients who are at
risk for micrometastatic disease, and there are patients who are
at risk for having subclinical residual local disease, and there are patients who
are at risk for both. So I think these two compartments tell us very different
information. The testing is complementary.
From a sensitivity standpoint, I guess sensitivity versus what
benchmark are you referring to?
I guess just like a ctDNA concentration, like a parts per million kind of thing,
or is it-
Yeah
... is it just dependent on the micrometastatic situation?
Yeah. From a clinical correlation standpoint,
of course, they perform quite differently.
We have a sense for what the limit of detection is from blood using
that assay. The urine's brand new.
This is the first study to use V96 in the urine, and so much
less information about the LOD.
Maybe just if I can, along those lines,
Matt,
I'm sort of thinking of a two by two table with ctDNA and
urine.
I think that you're finding that the ctDNA is not a
very particularly sensitive marker for residual disease in the bladder.
But maybe those ctDNA negative patients, what happens when you put
them through the urine test? Are those patients who
are maybe cured by cystectomy, like they have residual disease in their
bladder, they don't have micrometastatic disease, they don't need
additional systemic therapy, they need more local--
Yeah. Those pie charts that we showed, so 100% of
patients
with
undetectable ctDNA, so patients with undetectable ctDNA
who did not achieve a clinical complete response,
those patients were still patients who did
not achieve a clinical complete response with undetectable ctDNA are still highly
curable with surgery.
Most of those patients had detectable utDNA, virtually all of
them. So if you clear your ctDNA, any of utDNA, you can
still be cured with surgery.
Yeah. That's sort of what I'm thinking.
Maybe that's the ultimate personalized, like some people still need surgery to
really-
And we didn't show that in a two by two table form, but that's exactly what the
data show.
Yeah.
Mila Prokopenko Olsen, NCI. Amazing work, very
inspiring.
A question about A3A. We know that it is an
interferon-stimulated gene, and I see that you induce it by interferon
successfully. But where is it coming from endogenously?
So is it immune infiltrative cells?
So what do you think about this, Bishroy?
And second half question is, of course, we are
talking about A3A, but we're also thinking, what about A3B?
So what do you think about that?
Yeah. So Mila.
I see you are very excited .
Very excited. Yes. Very excited. So
two questions. So I think the first question about where is it
coming from,
so I think as you know very well, I think it is much
highly, all the APOBECs are basically a lot more highly expressed in
immune cells than in epithelial cells.
However, in bladder cancers,
I think something is different about bladder cancer compared to other
cancers, and in the sense that there is
much higher A3A-- And we showed that as I showed earlier,
much higher A3A activity that happens very early.
And in fact, in our last paper, same paper that I showed,
and other groups have corroborated this and showed this also,
that in normal epithelium that is
morphologically normal, there is APOBEC-induced mutations.
So this is something that happens very early on in bladder cancer.
I don't know, I only study bladder cancer, so I don't know much
about the other cancers, but my sense is that in some other cancers,
such as lung cancer, it could be late and
subclonal rather than early and clonal.
So I think it is very early. To your point,
though, I think you're alluding to what induces it.
So another interesting thing is that we know that smoking is the
main risk factor for bladder cancer.
However, when we look at the genomes of patients with bladder cancer, we don't
really see the smoking mutations. We see a lot of APOBEC mutations.
So maybe there's a link there. So that's something that we are actively
investigating.
Your second question was, what about A3B?
As you know, there are cancers that seem to be more dependent on
A3A than A3B. It's very hard to
sort of tease out the two in
different model systems. In our work, I think
probably the most telling part was that when we
knock down A3A by CRISPR
in the-- So we didn't knock it down, we obtained the cell lines from somebody
else who's knocked it down. And you can see that this
entire DASP phenotype is really
dependent on the presence of A3A, so it seems to be required.
And these cells still have A3B. So
can't completely rule out that A3B had something
to do there, but A3A seemed to be required for this effect.
Okay. Thank you. Good luck.
Good afternoon. Bernard Buys from Belgium, Leuven.
I have a question for Dr. Galsky.
As you know, the last years, there has been a lot to do about
circadian rhythm and our optimal hour administration
of immune therapy. We have 31 retrospective trials
in several tumor types across the world, showing a double of
progression-free survival and overall survival when immune therapy is
administered in the morning
This is still a bit controversial.
There has been a
single prospective trial, which is a bit doubtful.
However, it's a very cheap way to increase, probably,
efficacy. And I think that the trials of ctDNA are a
very good opportunity to test it, if ever you have the hour of
administration of the immune therapy of the first cycles, because you
could see immediately if there is an effect of the hour of administration
on
the circulating DNA.
So I would like to know if you've been working on that or
not.
It's a great question. Never thought about it. It's a great idea.
As far as I know, there's one study prospectively
exploring timing of immune checkpoint blockade in bladder cancer
being done in Canada right now.
Prospective?
A prospective study. But that's a great thought about using ctDNA
to read that.
Well, you could check it in the trials that you have done.
Time for one more question.
Mm-hmm.
So maybe, Phil, for you, and maybe Matt, you can give an input on this.
For the urine tumor DNA test,
do you think the tests which are based on copy number
variants,
which can potentially detect newer cancer,
or versus tumor-specific or bespoke assay from your
previous
tumor, would be better for following patients, as we know these patients
can develop newer cancer down the line if we are doing bladder
preservation. Which test you think would be better
to use for following these patients?
Yeah, good question. Something we've been thinking about.
So,
I have a couple answers. We've started doing shallow pass whole
genome on urine to look for copy number changes.
You can see them-- It's not quite as sensitive as
targeted sequencing.
The question about--
I think what you're really getting at is with regard to the tumor
evolution and maybe even A3A-induced mutations or
platinum-induced mutations for that matter.
When you do a tumor-informed assay, you're not going to see those things.
And so we've been-- Well,
Dan Landau, I don't know if you were here yesterday, gave a really nice talk about
more sensitive ways to do whole genome assays.
But we've sort of stayed on a targeted,
but not tumor-informed, approach.
I do wonder if
there's some room for a hybrid assay where maybe you
do a targeted assay
on the tissue and then the same targeted assay on the urine.
And when you see things that you know should be there but maybe don't meet
traditional calling thresholds, you still use that as a positive, but then you
have the rest of your
panel footprint to potentially detect new
mutations. We have a couple of data sets where we're looking at
that right now.
So I think there's clinical and scientific
implications to your question. So what I didn't show was this tumor saline
plot with the lead time in terms of utDNA detectability in
local recurrence in our study.
And unfortunately, we had a single urine time point.
Fortunately, we had a single urine time point, so we were able to see what actually
the implications were. And some of those recurrences were 12 months
later.
Wow.
Fourteen months later. And so I think detecting
new non-invasive cancers in the bladder,
obviously in a retained bladder, has different clinical
and therapeutic implications than trying to
identify
subclinical disease from a
prior muscle-invasive bladder cancer that has the potential to behave more
dangerously. So
I think we both need to think about the
performance of the assays from a scientific
standpoint, but also from a clinical relevance standpoint in terms of how those
will drive different decisions.
And my understanding is the current tests, they cannot differentiate
between non-muscle invasive versus the previous invasive,
muscle-invasive disease or even muscle-invasive recurrence.
They can only tell us there is cancer. Is that right, or am I missing something?
If you use a tumor-informed approach, presumably it's detecting the
same clone of cells that was there previously, although you can't say that
100%.
Yeah. Perfect. Thanks.
If I can ask.
Yeah. So we'll have time for maybe one or two more questions.
But Phil, go ahead.
I
consider Shoouren a good friend, so I can poke holes in some of his things
here.
I thought it was really interesting the principal components analysis you did at
the end there with the different treatments to show that A3A
seems to be a unique
program.
But none of those other
exposures cause double-stranded breaks.
So is
DASP
specific to deaminase? Or if you would have radiated the
cells or treated them with some other double-strand
inducing therapy, do you get the same program?
Yeah, that's a great question, Phil.
So we
used doxorubicin. I think I used-
Right. But the A3A ultimately is what you think is causing the double-strand
breaks, right?
No.
Maybe I should have been more clear.
So we had cells where
we treated with doxycycline to induce A3A, so these
have the doxycycline-inducible system.
And then we had--
It's kind of hard to find conditions that work for all of these and
make sure that they're comparable, but we spent a lot of time optimizing that.
So then the other conditions were doxorubicin, which is a
chemotherapeutic agent-
Right
... that did induce double-strand breaks.
Oh, that's good.
And we clearly saw on the Western blot that it is inducing
Brsk-H2AX that increases. And it does not.
So it increases FOXM1, as you would expect from,
as I mentioned earlier, FOXM1 is a transcription factor that
coordinates this DNA damage response, but it does not induce SOX2.
Right.
So it induces gamma-H2AX and FOXM1, but not SOX2.
The only thing that induces both FOXM1 and
SOX2, and we think that this is because of this
chromatin landscape change that I mentioned, which we sort of
don't fully understand. We've characterized what's happening at the SOX2, but I
think there's more to be understood there.
That seems to be unique to A3.
Okay. I apologize. I
blank on my mechanism of doxorubicin.
Thank you.
Okay, so, with that, I'd like to thank Phil and Matt,
and I want to thank you all for being with us today,
and I hope you have a good rest of your meeting. Thank you.